you know someone asked me a year ago why
i was doing this
why we were making a channel and putting
so much effort into it just to delete it
they didn't understand it they couldn't
understand it they were like it didn't
make any sense
why would someone put all that effort
into something they were just going to
get rid of they were just going to throw
away
and i said it'll make sense
when it ends and i don't think that
point could have been more properly
articulated than last night
when 1.5 million people
stopped whatever they were doing to
watch and pay respect
to the end of unis honest
because i firmly believe that the
entirety of what something is
cannot be truly appreciated until it
ends
you don't look back on what it was you
don't look back in all the minutia of
the detail of how it came to be
until it's already gone and then that
ending depending on how it ended
reflects
entirely back on its entire life and
that was ruinous honest
it was a year's worth of work to build
up to
one moment that one
second before we hit the delete button
that last second
that was everything and now it's over
and i feel
fantastic i feel better than i ever have
in a long time of making stuff on
youtube i feel
fantastic i know that a lot of people
are grieving and i'm not saying this to
try to make fun of people that are
because
grieving was the point the loss was the
point the
emotions of that was the point of it
the feelings the conflicted emotions the
the the the
the the reluctance to let go of it i
wanted to make something that was so
important that people would hate to let
it go
and that's what we did that's what ethan
amy and i
and everyone that worked on this did
every day we put in the effort so that
it would be so
hard to say goodbye and the harder it
was the better the content could be
and the more we put ourselves into it
the harder it would be to let go
and then we let go and that moment of
silence
when the screen went black and the
channel stopped responding
and now it's over and now i am back 100
focused on making content on this
channel
and let me tell you i have some amazing
things in the works
i'm going to take a little break don't
get me wrong i'm going to take a little
bit of a break
i'm not insane i've been working my butt
off for the past year
we all have it is a collective effort of
multiple people both amy
ethan the editing team and everyone that
worked behind the scenes to make unison
is what it was
i owe everything to them
they are the true heroes that may do
nissan is something special
and now that it's over it's time for me
to immediately jump onto the next
project okay so
cool things happening on the horizon uh
heist two is in full production um
expect that
sometime mid next year that's gonna come
out um there's an
oh actually sorry i gotta bleep all that
um i don't think that's ready to talk
about there's a lot of things on the
horizon
and i can't wait to make them and also i
can't wait just to get back
into great content on my channel here
and by great content i mean i got a bone
to pick with del monte
so i need to i need to make a serious
video calling them out
about their [ __ ] among other great
videos that i have in mind but
um it's gonna be fun i feel very
fulfilled
i feel exceptionally excited about the
future
and i have goals again i thought for a
long time
you know a few years ago that i was done
with youtube
that i might have been tapped out as a
creator
that i might have seen my limit and i
thought that i was going to slow down
and kind of wrap up and maybe transition
to something else but
there was this spark that was lit again
about
three years ago and ever since then i
have been getting
more and more excited to make
more and more incredible things
until i slide into my grave
i will keep making things i said on the
stream yesterday and i mean it with all
my heart
i hope i can approach my own death
with the same sense of contentment and
satisfaction
that i walked into that last stream
yesterday
because i walked into that stream and i
walked out of it feeling the same way
satisfied content
and happy with what we made
um is honest to be so thank you so much
for being a part of unisanus and making
it something truly special because
without you
it wouldn't have mattered at all
so thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye